um
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
my
[Music]
welcome to chrono snow i bet you never
thought you'd be uh
sitting in the middle of the string
quartet
maybe would you want to start off by uh
playing that violin over there this one
yeah that one yeah you need the bow too
and uh i rostened it all especially for
you so it's all set to go
well the uh you remember the
introductory
remarks were that there was a certain
moments when you
shouldn't get up and walk out like
when one of the musicians is holding a
violin but this is an exception
this is your chance to walk out
[Music]
i won't inflict it i won't inflict this
on you
come on scratch away scratch away
[Music]
press harder
[Music]
i once did learn how to play an
instrument i've no musical talent that
skipped me in my family but
i once did learn how to play an
instrument a guitar
there was a band a pickup band
made up of mit and harvard
mostly graduate students some faculty
my wife was on it she played the
accordion
ken hale our department was fiddler
great fiddler
and there was a ringer a
student from the conservatory who sort
of ran
it and for one concert they needed a
guitar
and they didn't have anybody to play it
so she thought she would
teach me how to play the guitar and she
managed to
teach me how to play one string but to
move my fingers
so that it would look as though i was
playing the guitar
and sort of carried it off so maybe i
could learn this
actually my son brought something like
this
home once a little bigger but not much
from third grade
uh the music teacher had shown the kids
violin and he was utterly entranced with
it so he
convinced the teacher to let him take it
home and
he went on to
[Music]
all get to the point where i was
thinking of becoming a professional
violinist when
an event occurred which i uh described
to daniel once
which made him decide to become a gifted
amateur instead which he is
but i never progressed beyond the first
[Music]
stream
[Music]
so no what's in your record collection
what's in your record collection
well one record is
the basis for what you just heard the
first
uh box suite which i
must have listened to a couple hundred
times in the last few years and many
times before
it has a rather special personal meaning
if you don't mind some personal
anecdotes
[Music]
my wife and i were married as children
basically had
we're working students never had any
time for anything
uh never gotten more than a short
distance from home
but early in the 1950s we did manage to
take off a couple of weeks over the
summer first time
and we decided to go to europe
which was a trick for two kids who had
really never been away from home and the
goal was to
go to prague where casals was
then running the public assaults was
running the fraud festivals
and the absolute peak
achievement what drew
some of the best professional musicians
in the world to this
little town in the pyrenees was his
playing of the dark suites
casaus had essentially resurrected them
from oblivion
and i think probably became the first
cellist to perform them seriously
the atmosphere was uh
indescribable i mean it's a prod is a
lovely little town in the pyrenees it's
right below mount honeygoo
which is the uh kind of symbol of
catalan nationalism
uh casals was a committed catalan
nationalist
uh actually by all rights my bones
should be up on mount koeniger
montgomery right now decided to try to
climb it
in a bit of abandon and
lost the trail halfway up and started
wandering around
and by this year's accident
ran into a shed of a
catalan woodsman who lived alone up
there
after he cursed me in catalan for
about half an hour he showed me a trail
back
oddly it never occurred to me to be
nervous i
later understood why it turns out the
male brain
doesn't mature until about 25.
so before that you think you're
indestructible nothing could happen
probably an evolutionary reason for that
but then
there had to be somebody in
hunter-gatherer tribes who was willing
to go out and
fight that saber-toothed tiger
it didn't occur to me i came down we
we had done some quite remarkable things
on that
trip we went through paris where we
were able to catch a concert by the
incredible russian violinist david
oyster
on one of his rare visits to the west
in rome we saw a magnificent
outdoor performance of aida at the
roman ruins terminator karakala
unforgettable
managed to get to the lasko caves they
were then still open
now sealed could see why picasso when he
went there exclaimed that
30 000 years ago they had already
discovered the secrets of modern art
and many other things but the peak was
what we were aiming for the proud
concert
we finally got to it the indescribable
aura quite apart from the personal
aspect
about us close to when he did play one
of the suites for sweden
and it's about as close to a moment
of sublimity as i can imagine
actually it had a further personal
meaning to me
the cassalas was a dedicated
republican anti-fascist uh
he played this he recorded the sweets
six of them for the first time
i think maybe the first time they were
ever recorded
right at the end of the spanish civil
war 1939
just at the time when barcelona was
under attack
and it soon fell that meant
franco's fascism took over spain
that he of course had to flee he would
have been killed immediately
the fascist slogan was a death to
intelligence
and he was a marked man as a republican
activist
went across the border and managed to
survive the second world war
he refused offers by the nazis who
admired
his music already very famous jealous
and they wanted him from berlin refused
he refused to play in
occupied france after the war
gossels refused to play in any country
that recognized franco
and he wouldn't play in russia and he
bolstered
the play in the former fascist countries
he was
flooded with lucrative offers to come
and perform after the war
but he refused he finally agreed to play
in prague
and he i think in the late 40s began the
proud concerts and we were lucky to be
able to catch one of them one of the
early ones all of this also had a
special personal meaning for me
as a child i was in the 1930s i was
closely following the dreadful
rise of fascism in europe
the first uh article i
wrote or at least remember writing was
right at the time of the fall of
barcelona
it was about how i won't inflict that on
you either
but it was about the fall the fall of
austria czechslovakian and
barcelona the kind of last hope for
some barrier to the spread of this uh
hideous spectrum of fascism all over
europe
and i knew something about him
by the time we went about his record of
the
performance heard it many times and
being in prague and listening to this
heroic figure a magnificent musician
carrying forward as he did every time
kind of a new performance of the sweets
to which he devoted much of his artistic
life was
along with everything else quite a
remarkable
and unforgettable experience so hearing
this these elaborations and developments
of it
is personally very meaningful for me
[Music]
if there's a lesson in all this which
maybe there is
for young people among you
when you have opportunities like that
don't let them pass
they can enrich your lives enormously
and
the memories remain and later years
become more
vivid and even more significant
so wise to exploit the chance
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for that that was beautiful
i've been thinking about this for months
trying to know
what
[Music]
to ask i think you know what i
what i'm trying to ask because of all
the people i've ever met i think you
might be the best
listener that i know of
and the ability to
really listen and get beyond the actual
words
and to really read and also get beyond
the actual words and know what's really
meant
is something you've spent your whole
life doing i think
and what i want to
leave with this evening is some
sense of how through a musical
experience
we can demand of the environment we live
in the leaders that we have
the culture we have that our society be
more
just our
um they just be more open
to the future and to what really needs
to be done
i've always thought music is
the one language that really doesn't
need translating
very much even though when we play with
a musician from afghanistan or someone
from
china or someone from many different
parts of the world
frequently we need translators to make
a non-verbal musical experience
but i'm just wondering if you have any
thoughts about this
there there are some real uh puzzles
about the
nature of music and its ubiquity
as far as i know every human
society that's been found has
some form of music and i think some form
of dance it may not be
in the tunnel idiom of classical music
maybe something else
but something and there's a good
question why
um since it's universal it very likely
originates somewhere in
east africa before our
ancestors maybe 50 000 years ago
probably
quite a small group of them left africa
quickly
spread around the world
so it's got to be something deep in our
nature that's
embedded there for some reason and
there's a good question
why what is it about music that makes it
part of the nature of humans it's a
come in songbirds have song but it's
quite a different phenomenon
uh music is not it's not uh
you know it's not instrumental in the
sense of trying to achieve some end
like mating or something like that
the it's been
there is one other a couple there are
few other similar
biological phenomena and one of them of
course is language
the is universal every
human all humans have it all humans have
the same capacity
and we know that if you take a infant
from
some amazonian tribe that
the tribe hasn't had the human contact
for maybe
20 000 years and you bring that
child to boston raise it here from
infancy it'll
be indistinguishable from my
grandchildren and maybe it'll be
studying
quantum physics at mit and conversely
which means i mean there are individual
differences but there's no known group
differences
which means that first of all it means
that language hasn't evolved
language capacity has not evolved for at
least 50 000 years
and in fact it doesn't seem to go back
very far
before that same is probably true
of the musical capacity but it's harder
to study i
don't think it has been studied in the
case of language you can
at least imagine some selectional reason
why it should have propagated it may not
be the right reason these are mostly
fairy tales but at least you can imagine
something
in case of music it's hard to see what
it is
that kind of puzzle has bothered
evolutionary biologists ever since
darwin and wallace co-discovered
the theory of natural selection
[Music]
wallace and his writings about it
was very puzzled about the fact that
humans
all have arithmetical capacity
again no selectional reason possible
because it's only been
used very recently in human history and
by very small group of people
but it's it's again universal so an
amazonian
child has the same capacity as say my
grandchildren
uh even if it's not developed in the
culture in which the kid lives
and he wondered why since it has again
no selectional value
he thought that there must be some other
force in
the in evolution beyond natural
selection darwin strongly disagreed with
them
but had no explanation very likely in
the case of arithmetic
it's sort of an offshoot of language
that you can
if you understand once enough had come
to be understood about the structure of
language you could
see how a minor actually simplification
of it could give you the basis for
arithmetic
but nothing like that is known in the
case of
music except maybe at a very primitive
level there's
probably because we don't understand
enough either about language or music
so it is known by now that there are
pretty well known that they're special
neural tissues
unique to humans which in
newborn infants and probably
intrauterine
uh pick out of the environment certain
rhythmic structures
uh roughly at the level of the syllable
so
probably specific to humans it's
probably the core
of picking out an amazing achievement of
an infant to
pick out of the whole complex
environment the data that's language
related
how children do that nobody understands
no other organism can do it
and picking out a certain rhythmic
structure may be the
part of the core of it later come other
rhythmic characteristics by about six
months old a child
has pretty much the understand knows the
intonational structure of the language
that it's been exposed to
maybe that has something to do with the
part of the development of music that
leaves open a
very deep question what about structural
properties of music it's not just rhythm
of course
well where do they come from it's
tempting to think that somehow they
grow out of a language capacity
something
sort of suggested by leonard bernstein's
famous
norton lectures 40 years ago
and there's been work on it since but it
still remains
quite a mystery but that's just from the
point of view of biology what about from
the point of view of our lives
well you know i mean listening to a
a a skilled sometimes remarkable music
perform
musical performance or seeing a work of
art or
uh it does
do something to us or should do
something to us personally
it shouldn't instruct us that
however good we are what we do and most
of us work
hard doing things we're expert at
doing well but it should tell us there's
something more
you should really be have an idea you
should be aiming
at something much higher and maybe
something
you can't achieve or even beginning to
begin to achieve like
i'm never going to be pablo casals
obviously or even
this but the fact that
he could continue to do it and that i
could
appreciate it particularly in those
remarkable circumstances but even just
listening to the record and so on
you know for many other things it does
should inspire us to at least try
to aim for something higher than what we
can do
regularly expertly and appropriately
so try to find some touch of sublimity
in your own
work or for that matter your own life
because even a life can
the humblest life can be quite beautiful
actually it
reminds me of something that i mentioned
that my son was an aspiring
violinist my wife and i
took him to a master class when he was
about 12 years old run by yehudi menuhin
over at the conservatory and i remember
there was one young woman violinist
who played a piece with just
absolute perfection it was technically
the most
magnificent thing you can imagine and at
the end of the piece
looked at her and said you know
magnificently done
but you didn't stop to smell the flowers
and that was a very meaningful comment
and it's for all of us we have to
somehow
stop the smell of the flowers there's
more to life than doing what you can do
with
technical perfection and listening to
[Music]
a marvelous work of music brilliantly
performed
it teaches us that the flowers are there
it's for us to
try somehow to smell them try to excel
try to go beyond what we're we know
we're capable of and at least aim for
something
higher in life whether it's in your
activities
try to make it a better world in your
work try to
achieve some goal that can barely be
formulated or whatever it may be
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you